machado la banque vous êtes fait larguer
vous avait largué quelqu'un cause de
madonna c'est quoi cette histoire
la wii s'est très vite très vite fait
très vite en fait j'avais un copain à
l'époque s'appelle alexis et dana
coiffure mais pas ton coiffeur mais
c'est pas le dossier et doit confirmer
possesseurs de wii maintenant oui en
fait c'est lui c'est un mec si il avait
une petite chienne un cocker roux qui
s'appelait madonna a à sienne d'accord à
chaque fois qu'on était ensemble
madonna était père agressive avec moi
ouais un jour où on fait des choses avec
l'état tu peux la couverture on fait les
choses un peu plus coquine sur un canapé
ah oui madonna ne m'en le mollet alors
moi je m'énerve
juni alexis maintenant c'est madonna moi
et il m'a dit si tu m'aimes c'est un que
c'est un lot c'est madonna et moi il
faut soigner là il m'a dit il faut
choisir célibat écoute moi je ne choisis
pas les deux j'ai donc finalement il m'a
dit moi je garde ma de naïma largué non
même il a préféré la chaîne à vous il
est préféré madonna a à moi à écouter
lire une bd dire jaillir le sherbrookois
et de quoi charmer mieux la cus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]